one of them is
uh uh regarding we talked about slavery
earlier i'm
a half armenian half assyrian and
if you know history which i'm willing to
bet you do you know what happened with
armenian genocide with the ottoman
empire
and the turks and all that other stuff
that took place this year earlier
you had both congress and senate that
said yes that event did take place until
i went to
all the way to the top and they said no
we're not going to pass her to make it
official
with the fear of the relationship with
turkey being hit with erdogan because
erdogan is
got the most powerful military in the in
the in the middle east
and if god forbid america says yes it
was a genocide
you know turkey may face a trillion or
two dollars of
reparations that they may need to pay
you're you're seeing a lot of
conversations come up and i have a
feeling over the next four years it's
going to be even more
the conversation about reparation for
slavery what are your thoughts
about folks who bring up for all those
years of what happened that maybe
there it deserves a reparation what are
your thoughts on that
well the problem is
who's going to pay whom right because
people who never had a slave are going
to be
paying people who were never slaves you
see that's what you have to do if you're
going to have reparations
and why is that right it means by the
way that some people who are poor
are going to be paying other people who
are rich
that's by the way what affirmative
action does in colleges
it means that rich people of one race
get in ahead of poor people of another
price
because if they just mean tested you
know like we have
we have the frederick douglass
scholarships at hillsdale college
frederick douglass spoke on our campus
twice really great man
and so severely poor
kids inner city kids difficult
background kids
we don't care what color they are but
we're looking for that right
we have scholarships for those kids but
they're just like everybody else
they got to want to come and they got to
be able to do it
and so we go looking for ones who are
like that and come to find out you can
find some of them in the poor areas
because most of these colleges that do
pick them by color according to a book
by a woman from stanford
they're getting them from the suburbs
they're getting relatively rich kids
right and that doesn't that's not the
deal
right i mean like you know the armenians
were slaughtered on mass
right and i
we the world should acknowledge that
that was shameful
right and you know the guy who did it uh
above all kemal ataturk
founder of modern turkey he was in any
ways a very great man
and he turned turkey toward the west
it's part of nato right
and here's another funny history is so
ironic
um in the last stages of that
dardanelle's campaign where churchill
tried to flank around in the first world
war through the mediterranean
too late and uncoordinated they launched
a land attack on the gallipoli peninsula
which is in the straits of the
dardanelles that that
that connects the black sea in the
mediterranean
which means it reaches up to russia and
all around eastern europe right it's a
key place well they decided they didn't
make it by ships
they decided to land some troops well
they landed some troops and they went up
and surveyed the hill
above them there's photographs from the
top of the hill of british soldiers
sunbathing on the beach and the general
said we'll go up there tomorrow
well the next day when they tried to go
up there this
turkish force had arrived
and it was led by
kamal ataturk it was led by the who
would become the founder of
modern turkey and he was a tremendous
soldier right
and the feat of that thing had terrible
effect on the career of winston
churchill
and my point about that is that's an
incredibly sophistic uh
significant man and for the west and for
freedom
he ended up doing a lot of good and you
know for turkey
he killed a bunch of people you should
not sweep that under the rug
i agree i agree and the the thing is the
right history being told for folks to
know what really happened in events so
uh that was an interesting answer on
reparations saying
those paying who didn't own slaves
to those who weren't slaves that kind of
makes you think about it but the
argument can
come back and say well like the argument
i don't know if you saw when kamala made
that one video saying
you had a better head start than i did i
don't have any generational wealth you
did you did have generational wealth
i didn't have any generational wealth
because i come from a family of slaves
so i don't deserve i deserve something
to give me the same
upper hand to be able to compete with
you that's the argument you're seeing
being made on the other side what do you
say to that
uh well two things the goal is equality
of opportunity
equality of opportunity will always be
imperfect and the reason is kids love
their
parents love their kids more than they
love other people's kids for example
i grew up extremely rich
my father was a schoolteacher in
pocahontas arkansas and he loved to read
books
think of the wealth that i got from that
and because he was poor
i learned how to work right and i
watched him and my mother work all the
time
and you know so i became a worker right
and i
love to read books now not everybody
gets that advantage
and you know i like to say you know i
might have been born to a rich waist
troll
and instead i got lucky but you know
patrick you got lucky right your family
a grand adventure courage
trouble right has that been anything but
good for you
and it's partly because of your
character and what kind of guy you are
but it had those experiences to temper
that character
you'll never even all that out you can't
do it
so what you need is and another thing is
now you're going to take a force right
because
the way you make money in a free economy
is you do things for people that they
like and they pay you for it
that means the free economy is
responsive to the needs of others
right so now what we're going to do is
we're going to pass a rule
that's going to take a whole bunch from
one bunch of people and give it to
another bunch of people
and that makes the people in charge of
that rule really powerful
and those people are people too
i like that and and and i got to tell
you i
you're right i feel like i'm the
luckiest man alive
like literally i literally feel like i'm
the luckiest man alive
and if anybody works with me they will
tell you i've said that a few thousand
times that i feel like i'm the luckiest
man alive to have lived
that i've lived so far
[Music]